[موسيقى]
أنا الدكتور سانجاي غوبتا مضيف
بودكاست Chasing Life على قناة CNN، إذا كنت مثل العديد من
الأشخاص الذين يشاهدون الآن، فقد تشعر
أن مدى انتباهك أصبح أقصر مما كان عليه من
قبل، ومن المحتمل أن
تعود إلى عام 2004  يمكن أن
ينتبهوا إلى شاشة الكمبيوتر لمدة
دقيقتين ونصف تقريبًا بعد بضع سنوات
انخفض ذلك إلى حوالي 75 ثانية،
ووجدت أحدث دراسة أن العمال
ينتبهون إلى الشاشة لمدة 47
ثانية فقط قبل أن يتشتتوا
وبعد ذلك يستغرق الأمر حوالي 47 ثانية.  25 دقيقة للعودة
إلى المهمة الآن، فكر في أن المواطن
الأمريكي العادي يقضي ما لا يقل عن 10
ساعات يوميًا في النظر إلى الشاشة، وهو ما يمثل
الكثير من الوقت الضائع، لذا ما الذي يمكنك فعله
حيال ذلك بشكل جيد؟ يقترح الباحثون هنا
القيام بالأعمال الأكثر تكرارًا
يومك خلال الجزء الأول من
يومك عندما تكون على الأرجح أقل
حالة تأهب عندما تكون في ذروة اليقظة بالنسبة
لمعظم الأشخاص، وذلك في وقت متأخر قليلاً من
اليوم، قم بالعمل الذي يتطلب أكبر قدر من
النطاق الترددي العقلي وفي نهاية
عملك  قم بإدراج الأشياء التي لا تزال بحاجة
إلى إنجازها يوميًا، ثم قم بتفريغ هذه الأشياء
من عقلك عن طريق وضع هذه القائمة
جانبًا حتى
تتمكن غدًا من سماع المزيد حول كيفية تحسين
صحتك ومطاردة الحياة أينما
حصلت على ملفاتك الصوتية